welcome back so just to review what I
was doing the last video before I run
out of time I said that okay you know
conservation of energy tells us that the
work I put into the system or the energy
that I put into the system because
they're really the same thing is equal
to the work then I the work that I get
out of the system or the energy that are
out of the system right and I said well
that means that the input work is equal
to the output work or that the input
force times the input distance is equal
to the output force times the output
distance that's just the definition of
work and let me just rewrite this
equation here let me well if I I could
just rewrite this this exact equation I
could say so the force input force and
let me just divide it by just just for
for kicks let me divide it by this area
because what I'm plotting the input here
I'm pressing down this piston that's
pressing down on this area of water so
it's input port for us and let me say
that times the input area well let me
call this input let's call the input one
let's call the output two for simplicity
so there's going to be some let's say I
have a piston on on the top here let me
do this in a good color like brown brown
is a good color so I have another piston
here alright and there's going to be
some outward force f-two and this is the
general the general notion is that I'm
pushing on this water the water can't be
compressed so the water's going to push
up on this end right so the input force
times the input distance is going to be
equal to the output force times the
output distance right this is just law
of conservation of energy and everything
we did with work etc so I just rewrote
I'm rewriting this equation so if I take
the input force and divide by the input
area let me just switch back to green
and then I'm let's say I multiplied by
the area then and then I just multiply
times d1 you see what I did here I just
multiplied and divided by a-1 which you
can do you can multiply and divide by
any number right these two cancel out is
equal to the same thing on the other
side
f2 I'm not good at managing my space on
my whiteboard F 2 / a2 times a2
times d2 hopefully that makes sense so
what's what's this quantity right here
this F 1 divided by a 1 well force
divided by area if you haven't been
familiar with it already and actually if
you're just watching my videos there's
no reason for you to be is defined as
pressure pressure is force in a given
area so this is pressure so we'll call
this the pressure that I'm inputting
into into the system pressure one times
and what's area one times distance 1 so
that's the area of the tube at this
point the cross-sectional area times
this distance well that's equal to this
volume that I calculated in the previous
video right we could say that's the
input volume or V 1 pressure times V 1
is equal to the output pressure right
force 2 divided by area 2 right that's
the output pressure that the water is
exerting on this piston so that's the
output pressure P 2 and what's area 2
times D 2 so this area the
cross-sectional area times the height at
which how much the water is being
displaced upwards that is equal to
volume 2 right but what do we know about
these two volumes and and I went over it
probably redundantly in the previous
video is that those two volumes are
equal right V 1 is equal to V 2 so we
could just divide both sides by that
equation and you get the pressure input
is equal to the pressure output so p1 is
equal to p2 so p1 is equal to p2 coming
out p2 and I did all of that just to
show you that this isn't a new concept
this is just the conservation of energy
the only new thing I did is I divided we
have this notion of the cross sectional
area and and we have this notion of
pressure so where does that help us
well this actually tells us and and you
can you can do this example in in
multiple situations but I like to think
of it with if we didn't have gravity
first because gravity tends to confuse
things but we'll introduce gravity in a
video or two is that when you have any
external a pressure onto a onto a
a liquid so on to an incompressible
fluid that pressure is distributed
evenly throughout the fluid and that's
what we essentially just proved just
using the the law of conservation of
energy and everything we know about work
and what I just said
that's called Pascal's principle that if
any external pressure is applied to a
fluid that pressure is distributed
throughout the fluid equally and another
way to think about it I mean we proved
it with this little drawing here another
way to think about it is let's say that
I don't have a tube at the end of the
tube is a balloon let's say I'm doing
this on the space shuttle and it's
saying that if I increase so let you
know let's say that I have some some
piston here right and let's say I were
to I were to a tenia this is stable
right and let me say I have I have water
throughout this whole thing let's say I
have water throughout the whole piston
let me see if I can use that fill
function again oh no there must have
been a hole in my drawing edit let me
just draw the water set of water
throughout this whole thing and all
Archimedes principle I mean sorry all
Pascal's principle is telling us that if
I were to apply some pressure if I were
to apply some pressure here pressure in
that that net pressure so if I you know
and out of and that pressure is going to
that extra pressure I'm applying is
going to compress this a little bit that
extra compression is going to be
distributed through the whole balloon
let's say that this this right here is
rigid let's say that's some kind of
metal structure the rest of the balloon
is going to is going to expand uniformly
so that pressure that increased pressure
I'm doing is going through the whole
thing it's not like the balloon will get
you know it's not like the balloon is
just going to get longer that the
pressure is just translated down here or
that you know just up here the balloon
is going to get wider and it's just
going to stay the same like there
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
intuition but going back to what I had
drawn before that's actually interesting
because that's actually another simple
maybe or maybe not so simple machine
that we've constructed and I almost
defined it as a simple machine when I
when I initially drew it right let's
draw that weird thing again where
you know it looks like this or I have
water in it or there's a bunch of water
let's say make sure I fill it so that
when I do the fill it's completely
filled doesn't fill other things there
you go so this is cool because this is
now another simple machine because we
know that the the pressure in we know
that the pressure in the pressure in is
equal to the pressure out right pressure
in is equal to the pressure out and
pressure is just divided is force
divided by area so the force in divided
by the area in is equal to the force out
divided by the area out right so let's
say let's let's have it let's let me
give you an example let's say that I
were to apply with the pressure of so
let's say the pressure in is equal to 10
Pascal's that's a new word and it's
named after Pascal's principle or Blaise
Pascal and so and what is a Pascal well
that is just equal to 10 Newton's per
meter squared that's all a Pascal is
it's a Newton per meter squared it's
very natural it's a very natural unit so
let's say my pressure in is 10 Pascal's
and let's say that my input area my
input area is 2 square meters so you
know if I looked at the surface of wall
there would be 2 square meters and let's
say that my output area my output area
my output area is equal to
my output area is equal to I don't know
4 meter squared so what would be the so
what I'm saying is I can push on a
piston here and that the water is going
to push up with some piston here right
so first of all I told you what my input
pressure is what's my input force well
input pressure is equal to input force
divided by input area so 10 Pascal's is
equal to my input force divided by my
area so I'm multiply both sides by 2 I
get input force is equal to 20 Newtons
so my question to you is what is the
output force how much force is the
system going to push upwards at this end
well we know that if my input pressure
was 10
Pascal's my output pressure would also
be 10 Pascal's so I also have 10
Pascal's is equal to my out force over
my out cross-sectional area right so
I'll have like a piston here and it goes
up like that and so that's 4 meters so I
do 4 times 10 so I get 40 Newton's is
equal to my output force so what just
happened here I inputted so my input
force is equal to 20 Newtons and my
output force is equal to 40 Newtons so I
just doubled my force or I essentially
add a mechanical advantage of 2 so this
is an example of a simple machine this
it's or and it's a hydraulic machine
anyway I've just run out of time I'll
see in the next video